[Music]
time now for final exam we bring to
people who marinate in the news for a
living to face off against one another
to determine who's really been paying
attention
this week's defending champion town hall
editor Katie Pavlich
her challenger former Trump White House
press secretary Sean Spicer
are you ready I've been learning a book
in audio to be clear whenever people
start with an excuse it does it either
it's a cover for deep knowledge or
exactly it's here the rules hands on
buzzers I ask the questions the first
one to buzzing gets to answer the
question you have to wait until I finish
asking in order to buzz each correct
answer is worth one point if you get a
question wrong we'd attract a point from
your total the best of five wins are you
ready ready to find out question one
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un had a
letter hand-delivered to the president
United States at the White House there
was something unusual about the
appearance of this letter what was it is
that Sean Spicer it's Katie sorry I got
confused
you're very large in appearance it was
very large and apparently she don't know
the answer so I'm it was for audience a
large letter to the tape we go this plus
sized letter from Kim jong-un the
president accepting that oversized
message from North Korean leader Kim
jong-un president Trump holding the
oversized envelope with the letter it
was a very interesting letter I
purposely didn't open the letter
The Secret Service open it I wanna yeah
wow I didn't know you see it's
impressive trust me she's good don't
feel bad if she beats you question two
this one multiple choice liberals have
discovered a new enemy Disney ironically
run by fellow liberals this week one
u.s. senator slammed that country for
quote corporate greed and underpaying
theme park employees was that politician
a Bernie Sanders B Alice
with Warren or C Cory Booker slamming
Disney for perfect read Katie Pavlich
Lauren B Elizabeth Warren was it
Elizabeth yeah you know in your defense
kind of interchangeable New England
socialists yeah what kind of I'm not
correct so it's zero to zero moving into
the third question here it is an FBI
agent found himself in hot water this
week after he accidentally fired a gun
into a crowd of bar patrons and shot
someone what was he doing with his gun
went off oh we have to go to the judges
judges you have to wait till I finish in
the question but for some reason our
judges possibly having been paid off are
saying that's okay
what's the answer Sean Spicer he was
dancing he was dancing
looked like he was doing it back with a
gun I don't believe you let's go to the
tape an off-duty agent at at Denver
nightclub dancing the night away
until his gun gets away watch as the
agent goes for a back flip these
handguns
let's loose falling to the floor and
firing there you go our judges say it
was the end of the question anyway you
got it we're out of time very good all
right question four and this is a tough
one I did not know the answer is
multiple choice I hop International
House of Pancakes is changing its name
people are upset about it needless to
say what is IHOP changing its name to a
pancake Zone B breakfast palace c by hob
okay is it by hub the International
House of Pancakes is flipping its p4a B
I hop announcing on Twitter that it will
now be called AI hub this is stupid I
refuse you literally cannot make me for
the record I think that name change will
make all the difference yeah they still
have boysenberry okay going into the
final question it is sudden-death
one-to-one why does it always wind up
here it's the drama inherent in this
game final question one more
multiple-choice question there is an
American state trying to grow its
population by literally paying people to
move there it is giving $10,000 per
person as an incentive here the choices
is it a Montana B Vermont C Alaska
Sean Spicer I'm gonna go with Alaska
Alaska says Sean Spicer is it this is
for the game is it Alaska the Vermont
will pay $10,000
I don't get it so they'll pay you ten
thousand bucks to go live in her in
Vermont and wrote work from home is that
it for a company somewhere else so I'm
told frozen state but it's the wrong
remote frozen state Sean Spicer I'm
sorry that's a tie but you should
[Laughter]
everyone loses to Katie she's an
unstoppable force it's a physics
principle I want to you Katie goes our
Eric Webb pool Memorial mug
commemorating the moment that Eric when
well the Washington Post appeared on
this show and that's how we felt about
it we never forget this we never know
that truly that's like a national
holiday on this show thank you for
stopping by Katie there's no shame in
that
that's it for this week's final exam
you're gonna be crushed by anyone but
exactly follow the news all week and
tune in Thursdays to see if you could
beat our news professionals
[Music]